so jake paul you're familiar with jake
paul i don't think so who was that so
you're like the one guy in america who
isn't at this point you don't know logan
paul or jake paul no the blonde guys who
are boxing everyone you're being
sarcastic i swear to god i'm not you
just said you're a ufc guy i'm not a ufc
oh gotcha i'm not actually you recognize
this character okay oh yes i think i
recognize that so
jake paul who is setting up all these
fights okay uh and his brother has said
before that he has aspirations to be a
president one day
jake paul comes out which by the way he
these guys have never talked politics
before they're not a
would you agree they're not necessarily
a political brothers where they're going
out there saying stuff about politics
but yesterday he puts out this tweet can
you put that up there he says uh
biden's accomplishments highest gas
prices
worst inflation plummeting crypto prices
highest rent prices ever created new
incomprehensible language which we don't
many people don't speak if you're
reading this and voted for biden and you
still regret it and you still don't
regret it then you are the american
problem that could literally be a gatsat
tweet yeah that's
oh that's true
i'm already a fan of this guy well we
just introduced you to this guy named
jake paul jake paul so jake meet cat got
me jake
what do you think about what he said to
taylor what tyler what do you think
about it
i mean i i i mean obviously it hurts
your feelings you don't like this kind
of stuff but i think it's interesting
that you're seeing such a
revolt against joe biden specifically
from the influencer community like there
were a few rappers that came out in 2020
that were wearing mega hats you're
seeing the paul brothers come out like
you're seeing or at least jake paul
rather you're seeing this pushback on
the
far left the progressives against their
policies and your ideologies and and two
your point about the academy i mean
that's why it's so important that jake
paul does this or gad said or you or joe
rogan that we're doing what we're doing
because yes the academy is is great
right that's a wonderful idea but we
have to have a full-blown cultural
revolution i mean like like full on like
we had in the 60s because even if
even if donald trump wins the election
or jordan peterson wins uh pm in canada
it doesn't make a difference because the
tentacles are are so far wrapped around
the institutions that it doesn't matter
what you do uh think about uh uh lisa
page uh carter page and lisa strucker
whoever it was the fbi agents that were
going actively campaigning against
donald trump i mean it's the fbi the doj
hhs everybody it doesn't matter and so
donald trump wins what's he going to do
he's going to rule by executive order
and be a tyrant i mean that doesn't work
so
i think it's wonderful to see this and
it's wonderful to see the younger
generation or at least some of them
start to wake up and realize what's
going on because yeah the
teaching a select group of people how to
be leaders is great in theory and it's
probably what we need but more so than
that we need a real
real cultural revolution you know i feel
i feel that way about guns
i feel that way about guns you know how
they're saying there's been 246 mass
shootings this year so far by the way
there was another one potentially
yesterday god got you heard about that
right what happened yesterday in texas i
did not hear about this a guy walked
into maybe this morning or yesterday but
the guy walks into a
uh school class with a gun and they got
him oh the school resource officer
yeah the school resource officer shot
him so with all these mass shootings at
their time yesterday we were talking
with you and michael francis
and the conversation was about well you
know what about the idea that matthew
mcconaughey pitched right raise the age
automatic background check you know and
certain weapons you can't have and you
know how many magazines you can all
anyways all these things that they're
pitching
and at the end i said okay even if we do
that and you move that in
that only prevents 5 to 10 of the mass
shootings that doesn't prevent the
majority mass shooting so uh tyler can
you mute the so so even if you do that
you're you're getting still the issue is
not going to go away it needs to be more
of a long-term
cultural change where you know every
other channel is turning these guys into
heroes where all of a sudden the next
person wants to rise up and do it again
so
i think it's more values and principles
to your point i think it's more values
and principles
and but for a guy like jake paul to make
that comment for jake to tweet that out
it makes no sense i can't see jake
saying something like that but for him
to say he's got a lot of young followers
that follow him i mean look at that how
many likes did he get 156 000 uh likes
that he got that means 156 and by the
way it is the it is his most liked tweet
ever i believe on the amount of likes
that he gets and
most of his followers are younger people
to agree with that this is a guy that's
got 20 look at his youtube channel how
many subscribers he's got wow
yeah that's this guy okay that he made a
comment like that 20.4 million
subscribers
so i agree with you that long term but i
also think the academy part
uh is more a longer term thing like even
sexual societies
what secret society still exists today
i i would argue that what secret
societies secret society still exists
today they have the power that they once
had
the world economic forum young leaders
foundation you say that's a secret
society oh that i mean they produced uh
justin trudeau came out of there um
there's a ton of political leaders that
have come out of the club is that a
secret though
i mean it's not like it's
what do you mean by secret i mean
there's only
20.
but it's not a secret freemason how many
presidents were former freemasons what's
the number they talked about 13 or 14
right
skull and bones secret society that's
from yale right that's from yale you got
it the illuminati is more like a
hollywood think or you know what you
know the whole thing that they do
it doesn't exist does not exist whatever
but there are certain secret societies
but the outcome here is to develop
leaders
those are the presidents look at this
freemason presidents wow people that
were masonic presidents of the united
states what's the number washington
jefferson madison monroe uh it's 15.
polk buchanan johnson garfield mckinsey
fdr is a part of it uh
teddy roosevelt taft fdr and truman
what's the distribution of republicans a
democrat in that list
well none of them because there's zero
republicans there because the first
republican was lincoln yeah so these are
all federal you know these are all like
original original uh type of uh
uh uh well fdr is not yeah yeah yeah
yeah
and then who's on the bottom right
that's guys
truman democrat yeah fdr democrat so
there we go but again you know to can
you pull back up to jake paul tweet
i got some feelings on that go for it
show your thoughts
well you're gonna say something no no go
ahead well look
uh i'm gonna remove the person from the
statement because
the person is an absolute troll
clown some might call him some may call
him one of the most hated men in america
but he does get eyeballs so i'm going to
remove the troll clown
this is the mma exactly well no the
boxer youtuber influencer
troll clown you would agree he's an
all-time troll
internet controller he's a great troll
right he's a great troll he knows how to
get under people's skin and i'm not even
saying troll in a bad way he serves the
pocket he's a positive okay absolutely
but as someone who has voted for biden
he's basically
saying hey buddy what does he say
if you've read this involved and you
still don't regret it then you're then
you're part of the american that you're
part of the american problem here's what
i will say
um
i'm not fixated on
i'm a democrat and that's it i'm gonna
stand behind my men no at some point and
this is for everyone left right middle
center blue yellow red green whatever at
some point you have to be like
[ __ ] maybe i was wrong
i don't know maybe i thought he was
going to do a better job than he is
i don't like this i had a conversation
with my mom last night and i was like
sewing notes and my mom
i was like mom how much do gas prices
need to go up or for you to like
for you to vote for trump i would never
i think he's disgusting what a horrible
human i go but mom okay my mom does not
have a lot of money you know
uh i go you know five bucks
yeah i'd still vote 10 bucks well that's
a cr 20 bucks and she's like well i
don't like you know so you can see kind
of her wrestling with her mind
but
this is why i'm
full-on independent at this point i mean
thank you pbd podcast thank you
valuetainment for basically saying all
right adam you're no longer a
quote-unquote democrat i think it's and
by the way i don't identify as a
republican either i don't think a lot of
the things that trump has done or even
the mcconnells of the world have done
are exactly something i can get behind
but i think this is the advantage of
just being independent open-minded
because at some point a lot of people
who voted for trump no matter what he
did i could sit there and shoot someone
on fifth avenue and i'd still wouldn't
lose a vote well that's a [ __ ]
problem
if you're just gonna vote for somebody
who shoots somebody on fifth avenue
that's my guy
at the same time jake paul does have a
point here at at what point when there's
a recession and gas prices inflation do
you do you have to question what you've
always thought so can i can i come in
with some hardcore science here sure uh
so as someone who studies uh psychology
of decision making one of the things
that we study is what's called the
anchoring and adjustment problem when
you anchor yourself in a position
correct what does it take for me to be
able to move you away from that position
that's very hard to do it's very very
very hard to do and so this not not to
engage in shameless plugging but in
chapter seven of the parasitic mind i
offer a methodology
for precisely doing that can i share it
with you guys please
so in chapter seven i talk about how to
seek truth right and part of seeking
truth is that when incoming evidence
comes in that is contrary to your
position you should have the epistemic
humility to to change your opinion most
people do not have that people don't
have that so here's what i propose
there's something called nomological
networks of cumulative evidence now it's
a big mouthful so let me break it down
for you let's suppose i wanted to prove
to you that
toy preferences are not socially
constructed right most social scientists
think that the reason why we have the
gender roles that we do is because your
parents are sexist pigs they teach
little johnny to play with the truck
they teach little linda to play with the
barbie doll and that starts a cascade of
gender role specialization okay i want
to prove to you that no
sex-specific toy preferences are rooted
in our biology are rooted in our
evolutionary history how would i go
about altering your position so very
much like jake paul is saying what does
it take for you to alter your position
on by then
i'm saying how could i convince you of
my position and so
so it's a very very powerful methodology
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
find as much
data sources as much lines of evidence
distinct lines of evidence that will
hopefully sway you away from your
position let me give you examples sure
so i can get you data from developmental
psychology where children are too young
to have been socialized and i can show
you that those children already exhibit
those sex specific toy preferences in
other words they can't verbalize why
they like this but they will they will
go towards the truck or the doll so that
already negates the possibility that
it's due to socialization because
they're too young to have been
socialized so that's that's box one i
can get you data from vervet monkeys and
rhesus monkeys and chimpanzees other
species where their infants also exhibit
the same-sex specific toy preferences as
human infants that's the second box
i can get you data from sub-sahara
africa different societies not western
societies and i can show you that their
children exhibit the exact same toy
preferences i'll just do one or two more
although the network is much bigger i
can get you data from 2500 years ago
from ancient greece where on funerary
monuments the children are depicted
playing with exactly the same toys as we
see today and then one final kicker i
can get you data from pediatric
endocrinology whereby little girls who
suffer from congenital adrenal
hyperplasia it's a disorder that
masculinizes their behavior little girls
who have that disorder will have toy
preferences akin to those of little boys
so look what i've done bit by bit i have
put the epistemological noose around
your neck because i'm giving you data
from across cultures across time periods
across species across disciplines all of
which triangulate to my position now
you'd like to think that someone is
honest enough that if they see all that
tsunami of evidence they will then be
swayed but here's the bad news even with
that much evidence most people put their
hands in their ears and go la la la i
don't want to hear it anchoring
anchoring so that so so what jake paul
notwithstanding that you guys are saying
he's a troll and so on he's actually
you know he's actually espousing a very
deep point which is our the architecture
of our human mind is not structured to
change our position we are built not to
seek truth but to win arguments and
therefore i don't want to hear about
your contrary evidence i'm sticking to
my this is why people want to live in
echo chambers and only just listen to
news that they agree with exactly but
the good news based on the scientific
breakdown i'm full on mega at this point
thank you for that i appreciate that but
which what you just said adam good for
you for
sharing uh where you're at and what jake
is saying for you to say okay cool
here's kind of what i'm seeing in the
conversation i had with your mom
yesterday and you said you know what
happens here this is this is where what
i've said and i've been saying this for
a while after conversation tom ellsworth
and i had
is the middle runs america period yeah
okay you don't need to win the left you
don't need to win the right you need to
win the middle yeah if the middle sides
with you
you're gonna win the election right so
for example if the middle is 12
if 80 to 12 is going to vote for you
you're winning right not not republican
not not democrat if 80 the middle votes
for you you're going to win the election
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]